Good morning.
My name is Alan Rice and I'm an elder here in our church.
I wanna start out this morning with my thesis
to this sermon, which is simply one word, peacemaker.
My subtitle to this thesis is a call to action,
and it's just two words long.
It is this, reach out right now.
None of that makes any sense,
but hopefully by the end of the sermon it will a little bit.
For the very first part of this sermon,
I'm gonna tell a little story.
For those of you that know me, you know that
through no fault of my own
that I'm thrown into some crazy adventures.
From time to time, I, I don't know why.
When I turned 65,
I wondered if God was gonna stop sending me these crazy
adventures because now I'm officially a senior citizen.
But a few months after I turned 65, I had another adventure.
So for now, they've not stopped coming at me.
So I was at half price books on May near 63rd street,
and uh, I was exiting after looking for books
and the, uh, exit faces, uh, due south
and there's a pretty good sized parking lot there.
But I was parked in a little parking lot
to the right on the west side.
And so I get out
and I'm just walking down the sidewalk along the storefront,
and there was a guy about 15 or 20 feet in front of me.
Now, I guess he just left the store himself.
So I'm just walking along,
just not even paying attention to anything.
This guy comes to the end of the sidewalk
where it meets the parking lot.
Suddenly he stops, doesn't about face
and charges me screaming.
Why are you following me?
Well, for the first time, I'm focused on
who this guy is a little bit, right?
He is a 30 something Asian American man in good
shape, okay?
Now, I had a little bit
of martial arts training back in the 1980s,
but if this guy never had 10 seconds of self-defense,
I knew if it came down to a fight, I,
it was gonna be bad for me.
So he is charging right from my face
and surprise to both of us.
I dodged into my right out of his way
and I keep going, okay?
He stops, does another about face
and goes, why are you following me?
And I'm thinking, you're following me now, dude, you know,
so, but the good news is, is that now he wasn't between me
and my car, and so I start walking really fast,
sideways to my right while he's still coming at me.
I pull out my car, key fob, and I click the unlock button
and my car's right over there
and the little yellow, uh,
rectangles on the side flash on the side of the headlights
and he stops
and he is like probably thinking what is going on?
I go ahead and go over to my car
and as I, I haven't said a word as I'm going to the door,
he stops and he says, in the most
emotionally desperate voice you've ever heard, I'm sorry,
we live in an age of rage.
So after this incident, I happen to mention it
to my daughter and she dia
and she kind of explained to me why it may have happened.
Apparently in the last five years,
Asian Americans have begun to be threatened
and attacked all across the United States
because of their race.
Why? Because of COVID.
I guess the completely illogical reasoning is
that Asian Americans somehow cost CVI stupid.
According to the Pew Research Center, about one third
of Asian Americans know an Asian American
who has been threatened or attacked because of their race.
And Asian Americans aren't the only
ones who feel victimized.
About one third of African American adults
said they worried every day that there might be threatened
or attack because of their race.
About one third of people who are poll believe
that Hispanics who are in America legally face a lot
of discrimination.
Ironically, they're discriminated against
because of the illegal Hispanic immigrants pouring into the
country over our last four years.
And many American Hispanics oppose illegal immigration
and yet they're persecuted for it anyway.
And then there's antisemitism.
A few years ago, I would've thought that antisemitism
and western civilization had died off with Adolf Hitler,
but here we are again.
According to Time Magazine, one third American Jews
said they have been the personal target of antisemitism
in person or virtually at least once in the past year.
We live in an age of rage.
We need what the apostle Paul is going
to tell us here in Romans chapter 12.
We God's plumb line to help us see
where we are building slanted walls
that are leaning like the Tower of Pisan,
a threat of falling over.
We need God to put us in right alignment, straight up
and down with his word and with his will.
Let's look at the passage for today.
Romans chapter 12, starting in verse 16.
Live in harmony with one another.
Do not be haughty, but associate with the lowly.
Never be wise in your own sight, repay no one evil
for evil, but give thought to do
what is honorable in the sight of all if possible.
So far as it depends on you live peaceably with all.
Let's start with the very first sentence
here and do some analysis.
Verse 16, it says, live in harmony with one another.
Paul is writing to the church in Rome.
So the one another here is referring to fellow Christians.
The ESV says, live in harmony,
but the literal wording from the original Greek language
here is he himself toward one another.
Minding. Now that's obviously contorted when you try to turn
that back into English,
but what it's saying is, is that each one of us are
to have it in our minds that fellow Christians are exactly
the same as we are.
They're not only to have the same worldview,
but fellow Christians are who we identify with.
They're not other. They are our people.
Part of our inner circle, they are us.
The great philosopher Aristotle stated that quote,
A friend is a second self.
In other words, a friend is another me.
That's what the apostle Paul is saying here in our minds,
our fellow Christians are to be exactly the same
as we are very selves.
For some reason, I've gained a reputation as a preacher
who uses props in my sermons.
I guess that's probably fair enough, enough.
Today I'm gonna use two props that you
and I have on us right now.
I'm gonna use our arms for the first prop.
I'm going to use the concept of a hug.
So I want you to imagine that the fellow Christians
that the apostle Paul declares are the same as us with
as being within the literal circle of our arms,
the circle of our harmony.
So any, even in our inner circle,
there are people closer to us than others.
Our spouses, our our, our sons
and daughters, our our best friends.
They might be right up against our chest,
but someone we kind of like in the church might be out
by our hands, but they're still within
that inner circle being the same as us in our hug zone.
And even though the apostle Paul states
that fellow Christians are to be of the same minding
who we identify with, I don't think he means
that we can't disagree.
Of course, we are going to disagree.
As an example, in Acts chapter 15,
the apostle Paul himself disagreed passionately
with Barnabas on whether
to take John Mark on another mission trip or not.
So right now, I want everyone in the room
to put your arms out in a circle like this in a hug.
Yeah, it's awkward, but that's the point.
Okay, so everyone do this.
I want you to think about the Christian friends,
family members and church members that are inside
that circle that you think of as you,
your harmony zone.
Now more importantly, I want you to think of those people
outside your harmony zone.
Who are Christian friends, family members, church members
that you have placed outside of your harmony zone.
Okay? Put your arms down.
I want you to get out pen and paper or your cell phones.
Turn the ringers off, and I literally want you
to write down those names.
Take a moment, actually. Literally write them down.
Now, let's define what a Christian is.
Christians are people who accepted Jesus Christ
as their savior and as their Lord.
By accepting Jesus as their savior, they're seeking Jesus
to forgive them of all their sins, past, present,
and future, which he can do
because he lived a perfectly sinless life and bled
and died on the cross so
that he could forgive us of our sins.
By accepting Jesus Christ as their Lord, they're declaring
that he is the one in charge of their lives
and not they themselves.
They will serve Jesus and dedicate themselves to obey him
and over time, to grow to become more and more like him.
Now having to find what a Christian is, we have to establish
what Christians believe, what they hold as right doctrine
because you can't say that you're a Christian
and then believe things about Jesus that aren't true at all.
We have to believe in the Jesus of the Bible.
You can't hold as a doctrine for example,
that Jesus is Bigfoot
or that Jesus is the lochness monster.
So at this point, it's reasonable.
Ask what issues are divisive enough between people
to place them outside our Christian hug zone?
I've had the high honor of being an elder in our church
for 23 years, and I've had the privilege over that time,
along with other elders
to help train new candidates for eldership.
One thing I've done over the years is
to ask them this simple question, how important is
a particular issue?
Then, because I'm a nerd, I introduce them to
what I call the scale of importance.
It's a 15 point scale up here.
The numbers in red from 15 down to just above 10 represent
what all Christian groups everywhere in the world believe.
If you don't believe that things from 15 down to just
above 10, then you're either horribly misinformed
and you need to learn the truth.
Or if you refuse, then you really aren't a Christian at all.
The numbers from just below 10 down to
one in green represent things about which Christians may
reasonably disagree.
So let's start with the numbers in red,
starting at about 15 would be belief in the
existence of God.
You can't say you're a Christian
and not believe in the existence of God, right?
Somewhere between 15
and 11 would be things like belief in the Trinity belief
that Jesus died on the cross for our sins, belief
that Jesus rose again from the dead Belief
that Jesus will return to earth in a second coming,
but starting just below 10 and going downward.
These are things about which Christians may
reasonably disagree.
The higher numbers not like nine would be more
serious disagreements.
Now, there are three major branches in Christianity in the
world, the Roman Catholics, the Eastern Orthodox,
the Protestants, our church, Henderson Hills is part
of group known as the Protestants.
Therefore, we're gonna have major disagreements
with the Eastern Orthodox
and the Roman Catholics starting somewhere
around number nine, for example,
for our church and for Protestants.
The main authority for our faith is the Bible.
But for Roman Catholics in Eastern Orthodox Christians,
the main authority for their faith is the church,
including things like church councils.
Having a different authority for your faith
causes Christian groups to come to disagreements
with one another about their theology all the way from
number nine, sometimes down further.
Do these differences from just below 10 down to one make
of the other two groups, not Christian, no.
The Roman Catholics
and the Eastern Orthodox are Christian brothers
and sisters, neighbors who are just on the other side
of a common fence from us.
Now, I have to admit that not all members of the Roman
Catholic and Eastern Orthodox churches are Christians,
but not all members of Protestant churches are Christians.
I would guess that we have a number
of people in this worship center right now
who are not Christians because you don't become a Christian
by attending a church or joining a church.
You become a Christian by accepting Jesus Christ
as your Savior and as your Lord.
So what are some other things about which Christians might
reasonably disagree?
I would rate clocking in somewhere
around Number five is a fancy theological term called
continuation versus cessationism,
which asks a really simple question,
is the Holy Spirit still active in the lives
of Christians today?
Does he still give spiritual gifts to Christians,
perform miracles
or did the Holy Spirit's ministry stop in the first century
ad our church holds
that the Holy Spirit is still active in our lives?
Amen. Amen. He convicts us of sin, guides us,
gives us spiritual gifts,
and we ask him right now to fill this room
and lead us all closer to Jesus Christ.
Issues like these cause Christians
to form separate denominations
and separate churches so they can practice their faith
with like-minded brothers and sisters, and that's okay.
It's how it should be. What are some
of the issues on the lower end of the scale of importance
that drives Christians apart needlessly, ridiculously.
How about music style and worship?
In the seventies and eighties?
There was a kind of civil war in America over whether we
should still sing hymns
or we should go to contemporary Christian music.
Get here on the radio. What about differences in preaching
style between pastors?
What about whether a church can go in debt
to purchase a bigger building to move into on I 35?
What about bitter divisions over
what color the new carpet should be in a worship center?
I believe these are ridiculous reasons for a church
to fight over more toward one on the scale,
but they're often the most common
reasons for a church to fight.
In fact, our very church has grappled with some
of these divisions over the last 60 plus years.
The second question I've asked, being a nerd
to ask the elders in training over the years is this,
how do you know you're right?
Then I introduced them to what I call the scale
of theological certainty, which is a 10 point scale.
This scale measures
how much proof the Bible gives on a particular topic.
So for example, if the topic is the existence of God,
how certain are we from the Bible that God exists?
I think it's not too much of a stretch
that says the Bible makes a hundred percent clear
everywhere that God exists.
So that would be a 10 in certainty.
What about the issue of whether
or not Jesus rose from the dead?
Well, that's another one that clocks in stunningly high.
Uh, just read one Corinthians chapter 15, for example,
but what about the issue of whether the church should sell
some of its land to the YMCA?
Where might you find principles for that in the Bible?
Well, the theological certainty for that is stunningly low,
and yet elders have to make those kinds
of decisions all the time.
So the reason I've introduced these two scales
to the elder candidates
and to us today is that it gives us perspective.
Perspective. Over the years,
there might be two elders in an intense debate.
By the way, your elders debate each other all the time,
and that's not just a good thing.
It's a great thing. Anyway,
two elders will get locked into an intense debate,
and I've been known from time to time to kind
of intrude into that.
Stop them and ask them,
where do you rate this topic on the scale of importance?
Often they'll stop stare at me, stare at one another,
and one will say a four
and the other will say, okay, a three.
And this point they're feeling a little sheepish
because they've been treating the subject
like a 10 or an 11.
Then I've asked, now, rate this topic on your level
of theological certainty.
What is your proof for your position from the bible?
They've looked even more sheepish and murdered A three
and the other one, a two.
The point is that all of us have a tendency
to lose our eternal perspective,
to fixate upon lesser issues
and make them 1 billion points on a scale from one to 10.
Our whole society is
invested in making this an age of rage.
Political parties want us to win, elect want
to win elections by completely demonizing the other side
and keeping members of their own party.
Outraged. Television news channels emphasize running stories
that enraged the viewers
so the channel can get better ratings.
YouTube specializes in videos that keep the viewers furious
because it becomes addictive
and millions of clicks help video makers make more money.
Rage has become an industry.
It has become a drug that the society is trying
to get us addicted to.
We live in an age of rage.
What is one of the main reasons that we ourselves
see fellow Christians as other?
Why do we not live in harmony with them
and why do we place them outside of our hug zone?
Paul suggests here in this Romans 12 passage
that it is simply this.
We think we're better than they are.
We think we're smarter than they are.
Verse 16, live in harmony with one another.
Do not be haughty, but associate with the lowly.
Never be wise in your own sight, repay no one evil
for evil, but give thought to do
what is honorable in the sight of all.
We can live in harmony with fellow Christians if we're not
haughty, which means not prideful, not arrogant.
The phrase associate with the lowly in the original Greek
means to be carried away with
that which doesn't rise far from the ground.
In other words, we should think of ourselves
as being the very bottom of the barrel
as not being higher or better
or smarter than anyone about anything.
Apparel passage in Philippians two verse three,
states simply in humility,
count others more significant than yourselves.
And the last part of verse 16,
it states very simply never be wise in your own psych,
but in our age of rage, that's all we do.
We're so absolutely right about politics and society
and everything else that anyone with a different opinion,
well, they're not just other, they're idiots.
The next phrase is also simple. Repay no one evil for evil.
But in our age of rage, we always feel
that the other side started it and we're gonna finish it.
We have to have the last word.
Our egos wouldn't have it any other way.
We have to show how right we are, if nothing else,
by ridiculing and destroying those who have the audacity
to disagree with us.
The last phrase that Paul gives us is this,
give thought to do.
What is honorable in the sight of all?
Is that your experience in this world?
Is that your experience on the internet?
That in the age of rage that Christians are writing
and saying and doing things that go out of the way
to demonstrate honor for everyone?
Think about the names that you wrote down are the fellow
Christians that you're not in harmony with.
Maybe you've hurt them or maybe they have deeply hurt you.
Guess what? Brothers and sisters hurt each other.
That's What they do, but they forgive each other
and they remain a family.
Christians should all be in one another's hug zone.
The another me zone, even if we've gotten crisscrossed
with one another, or even if we disagree on
what we think are really important things,
a center point, a center point in the division
of our society right now spins around our current president.
When it comes to individual policies, people seem
to be either passionately for all of his policies
or passionate against all of his policies.
Now, I remember a time when people in America would often
disagree with a policy supported
by a president from their own political party,
and they would often agree with a policy supported
by a president from the opposite political party.
Those were the days. That doesn't seem
to be very common anymore.
Now, whatever policy
or issue is up for argument it
as if it is the most important issue in the history
of the world and the other side is ridiculously wrong.
But how important is that issue? Really?
People have decided not to associate with fellow Christians,
even friends and family members
who support one side or the other.
But where do specific issues that divide Christian friends
and family members fall on a scale of importance?
Is it a 15 is the same
as if they didn't believe in the existence of God?
Is it the same as if they didn't believe
that Jesus Christ rose from the dead?
And where do our opinions rate on the scale
of theological certainty?
How do we know that we're so
absolutely right about everything all the time?
Is there overwhelming support for your opinion in the Bible?
Or is our theological certainty on some issues more
like a four or a three?
If so, then why are we letting our mere opinions throw
fellow Christians out of our hug zone?
I know people who in every conversation are going
to work in things which hurt and divide those around them
and they do it on purpose.
Well, that made for a pleasant meal.
Well certainly wanna go back there again real soon.
I know people who post nothing on social media,
but gotcha political statements attacking the opposite side.
Sometimes they even make good points.
But even on those good points,
I don't know if even one person on the other side is ever
convinced it's called bias.
And for the people that post that stuff all the time,
I don't know if when they're posting it,
they're very happy in their lives As a society.
We've all fallen into the horrifying habit
of seeing fellow Christians, even friends
and family members, not just as other, not just as idiots,
but as downright evil.
What are we doing?
We are ruining lifelong relationships.
Here's a news flash for all of us.
Our current president is not gonna be in our daily lives in
four short years.
Do you know who should be in our daily lives in four short
years, our Christian friends
and family members, our fellow church members, when we get
to heaven and we're hanging out with each other
for a few billion years,
our relationship breaking issue back on earth,
whatever it is, is not gonna seem as important then
as it does now, perspective.
Now, I'm not saying that the issues
that politics touches upon are not important at all,
especially the moral ones,
but even those issues aren't gonna be solved long
term by politics.
The Book of Revelation tells us
that the world is headed steeply, downhill.
We might have occasional steps backward from
that steep downward slide,
but the world is slowly inevitably sliding into
deterioration and decay.
The antichrist is coming,
and for a time he is going to rule this world.
To me, politics is really just rearranging deck
chairs on the Titanic.
There really may be a better way
to do things than the nasty here and now,
but the ship is going down either way.
The world is more and more declining toward hell.
And I, for one, I'm deeply disappointed
because at this point we were all promised a hand basket.
The problems of this world, it's violence,
it's moral corruption, it's anti-Christian hatred
aren't gonna be solved by politics.
They are going to be solved by Jesus Christ, our Lord.
The fact that the antichrist will rule the world
is not the end of the story.
After that dark time,
Jesus Christ will appear in his second coming
and he will set all things to write.
He will reign forevermore as king of all the universe.
Amen. An African American preacher in
2008 famously stated, our God is not the God
of Democrats, nor is he the God of Republicans.
Jesus did not come to take sides.
He came to take over.
And when Jesus is reigning over all creation,
we ourselves will be with him forever
and ever in absolute paradise.
Amen. But what of politics here in the nasty here and now?
What of issues in this world that cause us such anxiety,
anger, division,
World renowned Pastor Tim Keller once stated this, if the
resurrection is true, then everything is gonna be all right.
We are all here in this church today to proclaim
that the resurrection of Jesus Christ is true,
absolutely inherently true.
Amen. Therefore, everything is going to be all right.
So my brothers and sisters in Jesus Christ, we have to be
of one minding in harmony with fellow Christians, even if,
especially if we disagree
with him on important issues of the day.
Now, what about the last verse in today's passage, verse 18,
if possible, so far
as it depends on you live peaceably with all.
Notice that this passage needs
to be talking about a different group of people.
It says all. So I believe
that Paul isn't talking here just about fellow Christians,
but he's focusing upon the wider world of non-Christians.
These are people outside
of our hub zone of fellow Christians.
But even for these people, the apostle Paul calls us
to reach out to them.
The second prop I want to use in my sermon
for today is a handshake.
If you think about it, when we extend our hands all the way
out to the end of our arms, we're really saying to someone
that we want to connect with them even though they're
outside of our circle, we are reaching out to them
with an attitude of being at peace with them.
But do we always do this In our age of rage?
Are we reaching out to everyone to bring them closer
into friendship with us?
Now, it's not always possible for us to make peace
with everyone around us.
We can offer our handshake to them,
but they have to offer their hand in order for there
to be a clasping of hands.
We can't make them shake hands with us.
Some Christians who have done their best to live in peace
with someone might feel guilt
because they feel they're the cause of rift
between them and someone else.
But it takes two to tango.
Now, I'm not saying that we should let ourselves become
victims over and over again to abusers
who continually take advantage of us
or who continually damage us.
But the apostle Paul is saying here
that it is incumbent upon us to reach out our hands
to others to be at peace with them
insofar as we can.
So right now, I want everyone in the room
to reach out your hand in a handshake of peace.
Yeah, it's awkward, but it's no worse than the hug, right?
So stick your hands out.
I want you to think about the non-Christians that you know
that you have not extended your hand
to in a handshake of peace.
Are there non-Christian family members, friends
who you've written off and you will not
extend your hand to them?
Think through that, Okay?
Put your hands down and write down their names.
Hall is telling us so far as it depends on,
you live at peace with all.
One last thing we need to explore this morning
is the concept of peace.
Where does peace come from?
The answer is that peace comes from God.
The Bible tells us that when God made the first humans, Adam
and Eve, that they were in perfect harmony with him
and perfect harmony with one another.
They were in perfect peace, but they sinned against God
and they fell into what is called original sin.
This means that all humanity is born into a state
of being cut off from God.
Romans chapter eight, verse seven tells us
that humans in this fallen state are actually at war
with God opposed to him
and what he wants for us in life.
Because we're in this state of sin
and rebellion, we're cut off from the peace
that flows from God to us when we are in harmony with him.
But when we become Christians, when we accept Jesus Christ
as Savior and as our Lord, the Holy Spirit comes
to live inside of us.
Galatians 5 22 states that one of the fruits
of the Holy Spirit is peace.
And as we walk in the Holy Spirit,
he can grant us inner peace.
Even when we are facing the most difficult trials this world
has to throw at us.
John 1427, Jesus says,
peace I leave with you.
My peace I give to you not as the world gives.
Do I give to you? Let not your hearts be troubled,
neither let them be afraid.
One of my favorite theologians, Augustine Bishop
of Hippo famously wrote this while speaking to God,
our hearts are restless until they find
our their rest in you.
Peace. As we practice the spiritual disciplines like
confession of sin
and prayer, Bible study, worship, doing together today
and so on, we walk in harmony in the
and the Holy Spirit fills us with peace.
The title of this sermon is Peacemaker in Matthew
five, verse nine.
Jesus says, blessed are the peacemakers
for they shall be called the sons of God.
It is that peace which the Holy Spirit infuses inside of us
that enables us to be peacemakers, to encourage others
to reach out to each other,
and for we ourselves to reach out
to non-Christians in a handshake
and reach out to fellow Christians in a hug of harmony,
embracing them within our inner circle,
despite our differing opinions and our past hurts.
I want us to imagine a world where we as a church
are realigned straight up
and down according to God's plumb line
and are in harmony with one another.
Imagine a world where we reach out.
Imagine a world where Christians,
all throughout this church, look at their list
of names they wrote down and seek out those people.
This week, they seek out those who they have cast out
of their hug zone in their handshake zone,
and they reconcile with them.
Imagine friends and family members reunited in love.
Imagine people reaching out
to one another here in this worship center or in the lobby.
Imagine they shake hands with one another
or as I often do, give another a hug.
Imagine if they say, I'm sorry that I hurt you
or I forgive you,
or, which would be more like our Edmond culture.
Are you free for lunch this week?
What would our church be like if we all sought repentance
and harmony together?
Imagine that world,
and if a few minutes, the prayer team will be on the sides
to talk with you and pray
with you about whatever you wanna pray about.
Maybe you wanna become a Christian
and experience this peace of God inside you
that passes understanding.
Maybe you wanna pray about seeking peace with others.
Whatever it is, our church is here for you.
Let's close by praying together.
Almighty God. We need your peace,
the peace that passes understanding to flow through us.
Please forgive us of our sins
and wash us clean with the blood of your son
so we can have sweet fellowship, sweet peace with you.
And Father, we ask that you would
have your peace flow within us
and through us as we are walking in your Holy Spirit day
by day so that we can be at peace with one another,
in harmony with one another as you have told us to be.
In your holy scriptures,
thank you for your grace.
Thank you for your patience with us
and your kindness toward us.
We praise you, we honor you,
and we glorify you In the name of your son,
Jesus Christ our Lord.
Amen.